le lanceur de balles de défense
communément appelée flashball jeté une
arme non létale
utilisé depuis 1995 par les forces de
l'ordre
même si larmes s'est perfectionnée à
travers le temps elle a fait des
dizaines de victimes et a été la cible
de bien des détracteurs
à commencer par la ligue des droits de
l'homme en 2002 alors que le
gouvernement décide d'équipé la police
de proximité
l'association dénonce une dérive
attribuant ce type d'armement à une
police de proximité on la transforme
plus une police de répression plutôt
qu'en une police de proximité c'est
accroître le conflit et non pas assurer
la défense des policiers dans les
quartiers difficiles dans les
manifestations dans les annes l'usagé du
flashball est généralisé dans les années
2000 et les premiers dégâts sont
constatés lors de manifestations en 2007
un adolescent était borné à nantes un
étudiant perd lui aussi en ayant 2009 à
toulouse
à tel point que la commission de
déontologie de la sécurité se saisit du
dossier
en 2011 elle conseille au gouvernement
de restreindre l'usagé du lanceur de
balles de défense
nous recommandons de l'abandonner face à
des personnes qui sont en mouvement par
exemple à des manifestants qui bouge et
une recommandant aussi de l'abandonner
dans toute circonstance si il y a si on
ne peut pas améliorer la précision de la
cet avis n'est pas prise en compte
les agents reste équipé et les blessés
graves sont toujours plus nombreux
certaines victimes se sont rassemblés en
une association
elle réclame en 2015 l'interdiction des
lanceurs de balles de défense non à la
militarisation de la police non à
l'impunité des pauvres forces de l'ordre
et en particulier l'arrêt d'utilisation
d'armes de guerre contre des
manifestants désarmés contre des
habitants des quartiers contre les
supporters c'est inadmissible que ça
continue
les cas s'accumulent j'ai entendu une
grosse détonation et dans la seconde une
vive douleur qui m'a saisi les dossiers
finissent sur le bureau du défenseur des
droits
saisie à sept reprises en 2015 ils
appellent à la fin du lanceur de balles
de défense ayant clairement que cette
arme est dangereux on ne doit plus du
tout l'utiliser dans le cas de
manifestation c'est à dire dans le cadre
d'opérations de maintien de l'ordre
jacques toubon a réitéré cette
préconisation 2018
et encore une fois début 2019 au total
il ya eu plus de blessés en quelques
mois de mouvements des gilet jaune que
depuis la création du flash ball
[Musique]